really
four years ago I envisioned a forum
where teenagers passionate about the
humanities arts and social sciences to
come together to share their innovative
work and ideas with each other with
experts and with the world
my topic examines the factions and
infighting within contemporary United
States feminism and the problems that
this lack of agreement between feminists
could pass my project used map designers
like the map design as a way to
mitigation ingestion and increased
transit system efficiency the impact of
revolutionary my project is basically
investigating the most recent research
on the links between genetic variations
and increased criminal behavior so I'm
looking at a comparative literature
project between two Obata green avocados
work so the aim of my project is to
translate natural link english language
into a code that can be used by
electronic devices these wonderful kids
have put their heart into it
so I'm actually using the opportunity to
learn about this project and create a
wonderful idea from social gestures to
the role of you know they can be played
into voting into various environmentally
related challenges it's an absolutely
wonderful learning experience for me
I just happened to be here today and
I've looked at this amazing you know
presentations here from people in high
school can you believe that I was blown
away by the quality of these submissions
and the the passion and intelligence of
the
the students it was truly inspiring
they're able to get some feedback from
professors of really prestigious
universities they're able to see what
other students from around the country
are working on and learning and it
provides networking for for them and for
us and I think that gaining those skills
is really important and then they also
get to really go in depth in a topic
that they feel is interesting and that
they want to pursue I think was a great
program and spending three years on
campus was definitely one of the things
that definitely look forward to and
great speakers throughout the program
and the judges were very nice and I got
to meet some very inspirational people
just as the name of the competition
suggest I got to listen to tons of
really interesting and accomplished
speakers there was even a Nobel Prize
winner which is super interesting I have
now learned to wait for the moment where
things don't go the way I thought they
were supposed to go that is the moment
then you have the chance to actually do
something either because you are
realizing the way you thought of all
things is wrong and therefore there's
something to be lord that's the minimum
you know and and very often that's the
moment when the journey of the
intellectual journey takes a very
different time how often do you get to
come to a world-class University and on
top of that be introduced to a Nobel
laureate remember that innovation starts
first from within and when we all
unleash that mighty force we have the
power to transform not only ourselves
but also the world you guys have
actually presented at a national
conference and shown your research to
other interested peers and presented it
to preeminent scholars in your domain
that's incredible
you guys are pushing the academic
standards and showing that you are
changing how we think about the world
obviously it gets harder and harder to
get into the top schools for a lot of
these kids that's their their ambition
and this is a great way to stand out the
previous year's finalists and winners
have gone on to remarkable places like
MIT Harvard Stanford I think the kids
were very confident coming out of these
experiences you know they put a lot of
work into the posters they can discuss
it at a high level with someone who's
you know scientifically savvy continue
to do I definitely think I want to I
want to pursue research in my
undergraduate studies so that I can have
a career in academia at when I'm older
and I think this was a good kind of
starting point for here's how to do
research here to have the write your
first paper and here's how to compile a
presentation and present it in front of
people you don't know who don't
necessarily know what you're talking
about
I'm actually really interested in
linguistics I know four different
languages and I just recently learned
how to program and so this is a good way
to combine the two things I'm very
interested in when you're selected as
one of the 100 finalists to compete here
it's really you know it reinforces the
fact that your project matters I got to
meet tons of other tons of my peers who
are also very accomplished I got to have
really interesting conversations with
them about their projects I thought that
just being selected to come here and
really said to me that my writing skills
are as bad as like that it really
relates to the principles that we have
at MIT no making about the world overall
and all these project partisan you know
I have this kind of a background you can
say it's really relates to MIT I think
it's wonderful as a father you kind of
it is so fulfilling to see your son
sprouting and becoming you know kind of
the figure that you're seeing and
imagining them today I never would have
imagined that inspire would have grown
to competition impacting over 1,700 high
school students across 45 different
states in the country and I know inspire
will continue to grow and gain more
momentum in the future continue to be
curious we are very special people the
work that you do is nothing short than
this